and of course scooter never contacted me
or my team to discuss it prior to the
sale or even when it was announced I'm
fairly certain he knew exactly how it
would feel about it though that's Taylor
Swift slamming Scooter Braun at
billboards women in music event the
singer called out the music mogul while
accepting the woman of the decade award
following their feud which started in
June after it was revealed scooter
purchased her master recordings Taylor
claims she was never informed about the
sale prior to it happening she says she
found out about it with the rest of the
world when it was announced scooter
broke his silence on the issue last
month and pleaded for a chance to meet
with Taylor face-to-face to try and find
a resolution the definition of the toxic
male privilege in our industry is people
saying but he's always been nice to me
when I'm raising valid concerns about
artists and their rights to own their
music and of course he's nice to you if
you're in this room you have something
he needs the lover singer went on to
applaud women in the industry for being
her biggest supporters during such a
challenging time she also praised
several new female artists who she says
have the fire needed to create art
despite any criticism or judgment from
the outside world I see it in Liz OH
Rosalia Taylor Parks Hayley kiyoko king
princess Camilla Kibeho Halsey
Megan V stallion princess Nokia Nina
Nesbitt Sigrid normanni
her Maggie Rogers Becky G dual eepa Ella
Mae Billie Eilish Taylor ended her
speech by explaining the reason behind
her outspoken approach to creating
change in the industry I really just
feel like we need to continue to try to
offer something to a younger generation
of musicians because somewhere right now
your future woman of the year is
probably sitting in a piano lesson or in
a girl's choir and today right now we
need to take care of her the event was
hosted by Taylor's pal singer Hayley
kiyoko who spoke to et before taking
this stage
each of course Taylor is getting artists
of the decade I know you guys are
friends so yeah like what does it mean
to be here and celebrate her big year
together it just means so much to be
able to support one another and to get
to cheer each other on and celebrate
each other's success you know it's so
exciting and everyone who is getting an
award tonight and all of the honorees
and the attendance it's just gonna be so
amazing
[Music]